was 1br fully finished by the time you
got Netflix to look at it oh yeah yeah
it had gone uh it had premiered in 2019
at Fantasia and we've gone on a festival
run for like
six seven months all over the world and
so it was completely finished uh at that
point
um yeah and like I said they showed it
to him twice and they rejected it twice
until they finally said yes because the
VOD numbers were very good when we
debuted in uh April of 2020. how did you
get that initial meeting with Netflix
what did your distributor does it for
you Netflix will never talk to you as an
independent filmmaker like they need
someone else they can trust and talk to
someone who they perceive is going to
deliver the product in the exactly
technical the technical Perfection that
they're looking for and they don't want
to have to deal with some single person
they want to deal with somebody they've
dealt with before who has other products
with them let's say projects products
um it's it's it's something where like
they have to take it to them like it's
very few people who can directly go to
Netflix independent filmmakers and
forwards sorts who can go straight to
Netflix and try to make a deal with him
why did Netflix reject you the first
time unclear unclear
um you know look that there wasn't any
heat behind it like it's always a thing
where it's not special until someone
else tells you it's special right
and sadly like you know here's the truth
of it they're really more concerned
about their original programming and I
think there's a sense of Pride if they
did not come up with it it's not under
their sort of like um you know
incubation it's not under their
incubation places there are different uh
companies that they have deals with and
they are less likely to want to take you
and it's even more so nowadays I would
tell you like it's harder it's much
harder to actually get a film bought by
Netflix that's not one of their
Originals
but that's just what it is I mean the
other thing too they're not going to
help you Market it either like literally
we've been on their social media one
time and and having been top five for
like eight days and number one and you
know whatever else we put us on their
social media one time but why is that
because they put their Originals on
there that's what they're concerned with
is the stuff they've spent money
internally making that's what they care
about and I don't I can't fault with
them board it's just you know it's part
of their model
the second time they rejected you
any any excuse no just yeah it's not for
us just to pass okay yeah you know and
this is after after we had been
successful in our Festival runs and
everything else and we're winning Awards
it's not interesting what gave you the
confidence to go to Netflix
the third time well again wasn't us was
our distributor and distributor saw how
well we did on VOD and it was like it
was kind of like I mean it blew up like
we were like
number two or three on iTunes like uh in
the horror section like we were only
beating this was like the Invisible Man
and you know something like that like uh
so we were never gonna be the Invisible
Man I don't think but like this little
movie that's you know by and large
didn't have any real stars you know
they're stars to us but apparently that
is recognizable the rest of the world uh
but it had very few recognizable Stars
it blew up and it was like
trending like all over the place like on
Google and it was like you know Google
Play was doing very well and like all
the different platforms we had it on it
was doing very well and it had a big
pre-order I guess on iTunes which was
another thing and they and they and one
thing feeds another so when you have
good pre-orders they obviously give you
a good Prime placement we were at the
top Banner let's say on like iTunes and
like you know so these are all things
that people took notice of especially
Netflix and we're like okay there's a
good amount of awareness for this song
so this and covet was also happening so
I think that was another motivation for
them was like we're gonna need material
here so let's pick this up let's take a
chance so they did
how long was it on Netflix for
um we we were on for two years
approximately
um we just came off uh as of uh
December 31st but it was a great run I
mean a great run uh we know a lot of
people were able to watch it on there we
can tell from the social media and
different things and also uh you know
Nielsen has a Tracker that kind of tells
you you know how they think you've done
and maybe it's right maybe it's not but
you know I think it's a little right
so if your deal with Netflix is not you
know huge in the money sense it's still
worth it because of all the exposure
absolutely if you have a movie that you
think has a franchise potential or um
anything like that I have could have SQL
whatever uh you want as many people to
see it because if as many people watch
it as possible then there's awareness
right
there's awareness then maybe you have a
theatrical opening for the second one
all these things feed into each other if
you have a second movie then people are
going to go back and watch the first
movie so money's to be made that way too
so the the main missive you know people
were making like we couldn't understand
why we were coming on Netflix they've
already paid us their money they've
already paid us licensing thing why are
we trying to Hype it still because we
were trying to build awareness that was
the main thing whether it you know it's
very short-sighted to just do a press
push once for something you press push
every single time you come on a big
platform if you want awareness if you
want to build awareness if you want to
have enough awareness to get people to
go watch something theatrically for the
second one
how does the SAG ultra low budget film
become number one on Netflix
um from
marketing
um
what we did is that we thought we're
gonna have a theatrical opening right we
were sitting there in the beginning of
March 2020 coming out in April 2020 and
we're like oh this coven thing it'll all
blow over by the middle of March we're
like
we are [__] uh what are we gonna do
here so we pivoted we pivoted like we
made sure that like look we need to do
every podcast interview we need to get
reviews right and so you know look your
distributor like we had a publicist in
our Festival run and they were great
they helped us get like 15 20 Rotten
Tomatoes and credited reviews right and
then when it came down to our uh
distributor and their publicist they
helped us get some more but we weren't
certified fresh yet and in my mind it
was very important that we get to
certified fresh right so what we did is
we uh we had different openings that
were happening
between when we found out we were going
to be on Netflix we found out in May and
we were going to be on in August of
2020. so we had the whole summer of be
on VOD and to try to sell the movie
during covid when you know everyone was
literally at home trapped at home
and so we made it our our
goal in life to keep on getting reviews
every opening we would have in different
countries we would also uh for example
we opened in England in June we would
talk to the distributor over there they
you know Farm it out to somebody else
somebody said Hey listen how can we help
you in that market let's get we'll get
you actors we'll get you whoever we'll
get you the director to do review to do
uh interviews and whatever else so we
can kind of make it a bigger Splash
there
at the same time you know you're you're
uh publicist for your distributor helps
you as much as they can but they have
other movies they're working on too so
it's up to the producer to keep that
momentum going right so what we would do
is we would like look at movies that
were like not good movies on like uh you
know horror movies and C on Rotten
Tomatoes who'd given that a good review
then we would write that we would write
that particular journalist and say Hey
listen we're just doing a post-mortem
Val or publicist did uh did they send
you the movie oh they didn't send you
the movie Let Us write that wrong right
now so we would send in a movie in a
very way they would give us a good
review
and so we got another 40 reviews 4043
reviews that way and got to certified
fresh that was a big thing for us and
kept the reviews coming over that entire
summer right so we're always sort of in
the Zeitgeist we were in the public
horror Public's eye let's say right and
so we did that the whole summer we had
nothing else to do to be honest too I
mean if it added in covet I don't know
if this would have happened but we did
have nothing to do so we did this entire
summer and then we were waiting for like
the first day we were coming on to
Netflix we thought like we'd be lucky if
we cracked the top ten well not only we
cracked the top 10 we wanted the top
five first day and stayed in the top
five five
four four three two one and then three
and then four and then five and then we
were just gone we just didn't we didn't
say in the top ten it just disappeared
and we were like well that was a good
run you know so I tell you like
everything he had done to that point
whether it be the festival run the
strategy we had there
um how we designed the poster and also
the trailer we worked very connectedly
with our distributor to design all those
things
uh and then once we actually debuted on
VOD
um and all the things leading up to that
and then pivoting to just doing podcasts
and interviews and everything we could
do during that summer
led up to us being number one that's
what happened like that's the the
marketing that we did everything we did
and look
it could have seemed at a certain point
where there was just like it's a Fool's
errand to try and do this stuff the
movie's already out on VOD it's probably
the best it's going to be oh now it's on
Netflix well I got to number one well we
should just we've done it we finished no
you haven't finished
every time you debut in a new set of
platforms you need to do a publicity
push especially if you want to have a
sequel or a franchise out of it it's
very important that you build the
awareness in such a way that any
subsequent sequels will have at least
eyeballs on them I don't know if they'll
be good or bad hopefully they'll be very
good but at least they'll have eyeballs
on them and first will get eyeballs
again
that's what you do
why did you decide to move one BR off of
Netflix and onto 2B well you know to be
fair uh I the avod marketplace whether
it be 2B peacock uh Voodoo Pluto TV Roku
TV Plex Zuma there's like a billion of
them right well we went on to eight new
platforms starting January one and I
thought at first because we had the
first deal we did with Netflix was for a
year then we re-up with them for a
second here right but we could have in
the meantime instead of re-upping
another year with them we could have
gone straight to avot platforms and I
felt like that would have probably made
it made us a lot more money than
probably the deal we were getting from
Netflix let's say right but you'd go
with Netflix because by and large it has
the most viewership of any platform in
the United States and Canada at least
there's 74 million households that have
it 2.11 is the average household so 140
something million people have access to
it that we know that aren't stealing it
let's say because there's probably more
that are stealing it although they're
supposed to crack down on it this year
um so let's call it 116 million people
that already have it well if you do want
to be a franchise then take the shitty
money and go and be on Netflix for
another year that's which we did
now we're at the point where we're like
we feel like enough people seen it on
Netflix we need to expand out like 2B
for example has 60 million subscribers
peacock is like 40 to 50 million or
something like this right there's so I
mean they're probably you know a
crossover between the people having
Netflix too let's be honest but there's
a lot of different
um avod platforms where people like you
know can't afford Netflix right now it's
a tough time in the economy and people
don't mind watching like some of the
commercials with these things because
the commercials are so short they're so
short in fact that you don't even have
time to go to the restroom and come back
like you literally have to pause the
movie because you're going to miss some
of it unless you you know you're the
fastest peer in the world uh so the the
idea is that uh moving on is avod
platforms a is one of the most
profitable things that independent
filmmakers can do at this point
especially if you have something that
people are going to watch all the way
through because you get paid pretty much
per commercial per impression like they
call it like I mean per impression that
people watch a commercial it's like
there's like 22 commercials like on a 2B
movie and there's like 17 or 15 during a
peacock movie and stuff like that so
filmmakers can make anywhere from like
you know approximately a cent a
commercial
but some some people say between 10 and
like you know freebie for example pays
you per hour they pay you uh 10 cents
per hour so if your movie's an hour and
a half you get 15 cents per view if they
watch the whole thing
we know that from testing a movie or
maybe had very little rejection and
people would watch it all the way
through we had a very high retention
rate so we felt very strongly that
people will watch the whole movie and
watch all the way through commercials in
some way
so we wanted to bring it on there as
soon as possible we waited another year
on Netflix to have more people watch the
film but now it's the perfect time well
we're going to be shooting a sequel for
the movie this year to be on another set
of platforms make some money you know
hopefully make you know all of our money
back for the film we're not quite there
yet almost there uh but uh
have a bunch of different people who
haven't seen it before a new audience
watched the film right and then uh you
know make some money and bring out the
second film and then hopefully that has
such a Groundswell because people have
seen the first movie that people want to
pay theatrically to see it hopefully